يُطلق عليه فندق كوخ الإسكيمو مخبأً مخفيًا
مرتفعًا في الخارج السويسري الذي تم بناؤه كل عام
من الثلج المكدس ، وهو مكان مثالي
للدب لقضاء شتاء طويل بارد ويمكنني
أن أخبرك ما هي الرحلة الملحمية
حتى الآن للوصول إلى هنا  انزلقنا على
مسار أزرق وصلنا إلى قمة
الجبل حيث تم سحقنا وتأرجحنا من
قبل المتزلجين مرحبًا بكم في قصر الجليد الخاص بي ، لذلك
نحن هنا عند مدخل كوخ الإسكيمو
ستأخذني في جولة يمكنني أن
أرى  علامة مميزة أيضًا لدينا الكثير من
الخيارات
هنا بالضبط يمكننا رؤيتك كما لو كان لدينا
هاواي VF اليابان ولدينا Tess mini
Island ودعنا نذهب هذا الفندق به كل
الضروريات العارية خمسة عشر eglise لذا
الكثير من المتسع لكثير من الدببة
يا بلدي  يا إلهي الآن ، هذه قطعة مهمة
من أحجية الصور المقطوعة لم أكن
أعتبرها جيدة ، لقد أحضرتني إلى
غرفة الأميرة الخاصة بي هنا لدينا سرير مصنوع
من ثلاجة ثلجية بعض المراتب من
جلد الغنم لدينا كيس نوم داخلي
يمكن للناس استخدامه  لديك ضوء
هناك إذا لم تجرب هذا أبدًا  لست
متأكدًا من أنك ستصدق مدى الراحة والراحة التي
يوفرها
هذا السرير ولكن كل ما يمكنني قوله هو أنه
كما تعلمون مستلقين على سحابة باردة
علمت نفسي فيها مثل